a chance to stand back and evaluate a
sickness at the heart of Europe
religious radicalism and fundamentalism
the chance at a meeting on
inter-religious dialogue to find ways to
restore tolerance and dignity the world
is in a torment because here politics
and religion are mixed up again then I
think it's perhaps our chance in this
cooperation to overcome this terrible
situation this is not some soft option
anymore we have in our midst a real
concern about terrorism of concern over
whether we can practice our faith in
real security a recent series of attacks
in Europe have heightened concerns
coupled to the rise of so-called Islamic
state and young disaffected Europeans
joining their ranks blame the absence of
values and prospect said one leader hola
mahdessian ana fond adieu zone copia de
anoche divyani urban kilulu coupable
dellatossa chip avoca anticipate a
halogen others accepted in all religions
the potential for extremism but a
greater potential for higher values NCA
may leave re religione gusano presenti
in turn a questo down low for tono de
Valory fundamentally perlick roshita
request a robot this was a charged
meeting on a charged issue long overdue
for some timely for others in tackling a
defining issue in Europe